SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENT IN
THE DESHAUN WATSON CIVIL
LITIGATION 22 PLAINTIFFS
FILING LAWSUITS AGAINST
WATSON ALLEGED MISCONDUCT
DURING MASSAGE THERAPY
SESSIONS WATSON GOING ALL-IN
IF THERE WAS ANY DOUBT THAT
WATSON AND HIS CAN'T BELIEVE
THAT THESE VICTIMS ALLEGED
VICTIMS WERE TELLING THE
TRUTH. THEY MADE IT CLEAR IN
THE FILING. IT WAS JUST A
MONEY TO CASES AND IN A
STATEMENT FROM RUSTY HARDENED
TO SEAN WATSON'S LAWYER. THEY
BELIEVE ALL 22 OF THE
PLAINTIFFS ARE LYING. THAT IS
BOLD CLAIM AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO
BE DIFFICULT TO SUSTAIN
BECAUSE IT'S ONE THING TO
CATCH ONE IN A LIE.
IT'S ONE THING TO CATCH TO
IT'S ONE THING TO CATCH 22
GET ALL 22 AND TO SHOW THAT
22 MAGNUM MONEY GRAB THAT IS
A BOLD BOLD BOLD MOVE MILES.
WELL, IT SEEMED REALLY BOLD
TO ME. JUST READING IT RIGHT
AND, YOU KNOW READING BOTH
THE COURT FILING IN THAN THE
STATEMENT FROM RUSTY HARDENED.
I JUST I FEEL LIKE EVEN WHEN
YOU KNOW, HARDEN IS TALKING
AND HE SAYS, YOU KNOW,
THERE ARE ONLY TWO OF THE
TWENTY TWO LAWSUITS THAT
ALLEGED FOR SEXUAL ACTIVITY.
IT JUST WHEN YOU'RE SAYING
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF IT'S
ONLY RIGHT IT'S ONE MORE THAN
ONE. IT DOESN'T MATTER THAT'S
STILL A VERY SERIOUS
ALLEGATION. AND SO I JUST
FEEL LIKE YES, IT'S
ABSOLUTELY SOMETHING VERY
VERY BOLD, AND I GUESS MY
QUESTION TO YOU MIKE. DID
THEY HAVE TO GO THIS BOLD?
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE THEY
DIDN'T BUT WHEN YOU'RE GOING
IN YOUR A DEFENSE ATTORNEY,
I FEEL LIKE I CAN'T
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU ALSO WOULD
WANT TO BE VERY BOLD AND
TAKING A STEP TO DENY THE
ALLEGATION.
THERE ARE CERTAIN DOCUMENTS
THAT WILL BE FILED IN
HIGH-PROFILE CASES FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE COURT. THERE
ARE CERTAIN DOCUMENTS THAT
WILL BE FILED IN SUCH CASES
FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE MEDIA.
THIS IS A DOCUMENT THAT WAS
FILED SOLELY FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE MEDIA. THIS IS TAKING
THE COURT OF LAW PROCESS AND
TURNING IT INTO A COURT OF
PUBLIC OPINION WEAPON PLAIN
AND SIMPLE THERE'S NO
RELEVANCE TO THE CLAIMS OF
EACH OF THE INDIVIDUAL
PLAINTIFFS AS A
RELATES TO THE CLAIMS THAT
THE OTHERS ARE LYING IN SOME
WAY OR BRAGGED ABOUT GIVING
ME DESHAUN WATSON A MASSAGE
OR SHOWED UP TO MASSAGE HIM
AGAIN AFTER AN ALLEGED
INCIDENT OF MISCONDUCT OR
TOLD THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS HOW
GREAT THE EXPERIENCE WAS.
IT'S AN EFFORT TO BRING DOWN
ALL 22 BY TAKING
ON THE ONES WHERE SO FAR.
THEY'VE FOUND PROBLEMS AND I
DIDN'T SEE ASHLEY. SO LISA'S
NAME FOR EXAMPLE MENTIONED
AMONG
LIST OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHERE
THEY HAVE A SPECIFIC CONCERN
SPECIFIC PROOF SPECIFIC
ALLEGATION BASED UPON THE
FACT THAT NOW HAVE ALL THE
NAMES. SO THIS WAS FOR OUR
BENEFIT. THIS WAS THE BIG
HE'LL OF THE POSITION AND THE
KEY SENTENCE FROM THE RUSTY
HARDENED STATEMENT THAT WE
HAD UP ON THE SCREEN. THERE'S
A LOT THERE BUT THERE'S ONE
SENTENCE THAT SUMS IT ALL UP
THE ANSWER TO THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER WE ARE SAYING THAT
ALL 22 PLAINTIFFS ARE LYING
ABOUT THE ALLEGATIONS OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT BY MR.
WATSON IS A RESOUNDING. YES.
THEY ARE CLAIMING THAT ALL 22
ARE LIARS, AND I THINK
THEY'RE DOING THIS MILES TO
APPLY SETTLEMENT PRESSURE TO
THE PLAINTIFF.
SOOOO, I THINK THEY'VE BEEN
TRYING TO GET TONY BUSBY WHO
REPRESENTS ALL OF THEM TO
COME TO THE TABLE AND TO TRY
TO WORK SOMETHING OUT BUT
BUSBY KNOWS THERE'S BENEFIT
IN BEING UNPREDICTABLE.
THERE'S VALUE IN BEING COY,
IT COULD DRIVE UP THE PRICE
FOR EACH OF THE INDIVIDUAL
PLAINTIFFS THINK WHAT HE'S
TRYING TO DO IS PUT PRESSURE
ON BUSBY THAT'S GOING TO COME
FROM HIS CLIENTS BECAUSE NOW
HIS PHONE IS GOING TO START
RINGING AND CLIENTS AGAIN
SAID, WHAT DID YOU SEE WHAT
THEY SAID ABOUT ME? WHAT ARE
WE GOING TO DO ABOUT THIS?
AND IF YOU START GETTING
SOME CLIENTS WHO ARE FEELING
A LITTLE
PROBABLY A LITTLE LESS
CONFIDENT ABOUT THEIR CASES.
THAT'S THE THING THAT COULD
PUSH THE WHOLE CASE TO THE
TABLE AND THAT COULD BE THE
THING THAT ALLOWS A POTENTIAL
BECAUSE REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THINK IT'S IN DESHAWN  STILL
WATSON'S INTEREST TO HAVE HIS
RECKONING TO WORK IT OUT TO
THE SATISFACTION OF THE INTO
INDIVIDUALS AND MOVE ON AND
THIS MAY HAVE BEEN INTENDED
TO LAY THE FOUNDATION FOR
THAT. WELL, THEN THAT MAKES
SENSE. I MEAN THE I FEEL LIKE
IF YOU'RE RUSTY HARDENED
RIGHT THE QUICKER THAT YOU
YOU CAN GET TONY BUSBY TO
THE TABLE.
WITH ALL 22 OF THESE WOMEN
WHO ARE SUING DESHAUN WATSON
AND THEN SAY, HOW CAN WE
RESOLVE THIS AND FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO RESOLVE IT THAT'S
BETTER FOR DESHAUN WATSON IN
HIS LIFE AND IN HIS CAREER
BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE TWO
THINGS THAT I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW, IF YOU ARE REPRESENTING
DESHAUN WATSON, THOSE ARE
YOUR INTERESTS, RIGHT? WHAT
IS THE BEST THING FOR MY
CLIENT IN HIS LIFE AND IN HIS
CAREER SO FROM THAT
STANDPOINT IF THIS STATEMENT
RELEASED VERA FOR OUR BENEFIT
SO THAT WE'RE NOW TALKING
ABOUT IT AND WE ARE NOW
BASICALLY SAYING ALL OF THESE
THINGS AND REPEATING WHAT
RUSTY HARDIN WAS ABLE TO PUT
IN THOSE BOTH DOCUMENTS THERE.
THEN WE ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO KIND OF HAVE THAT COURT OF
PUBLIC OPINION START
MAYBE CHANGING RIGHT? I
THINK THAT'S AT LEAST THE AIM
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THE
RUSTY HARDEN HAS SAID THAT
YOU KNOW, THEY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS STILL SOME
HERE IN THE COURT OF PUBLIC
22 ALLEGED VICTIMS THAT
NUMBER IS STILL ALWAYS GOING
TO BE IN PEOPLE'S MINDS AND
SO I DON'T KNOW HOW
SUCCESSFUL OR UNSUCCESSFUL
THE EFFORT IS TODAY FROM
DESHAWN WATSON'S CAMP IN
SORT OF CHANGING THAT
PERCEPTION THE FACT THAT ALL
22 LAWSUITS WERE OR ARE BEING
RESPONDED TO NOW IT'S
PUTTING THE PRESSURE ON THE
THE STAGE FOR A POTENTIAL G
RESOLUTION. THAT WOULD ALLOW
RUSTY HARDENED TO CLAIM ON
DESEAN WATSON'S BEHALF THAT
THIS AGGRESSIVE RESPONSE.
EXPOSING THE PROBLEMS IS WHAT
IS WHAT CAUSED THESE CASES TO
SETTLE? THAT'S A WAY TO MAYBE
GET BACK SOME OF THE
REPUTATION ALTHOUGH EVEN IF
THIS ALL GOES AWAY TODAY,
THERE'S GOING TO BE PEOPLE
WHO SAY WHAT THE HELL'S
DESHAUN WATSON DOING GETTING
ALL THESE MASSAGES AND HE'S
ADMITTED THROUGH HIS LAWYER
TO SOME OF THESE MASSAGES
BECOMING CONSENSUAL SEXUAL
ACTIVITY. SO THAT PART OF IT
IS NEVER GOING AWAY. HE JUST
NEEDS TO HOPE THAT HE CAN
FIND A WAY TO DISTANCE
HIMSELF FROM THE PERCEPTION
THAT THERE WAS WRONGDOING
HAPPENING.
SEXUAL BEHAVIOR OCCURRING OR  T
PEOP
LE
B